so what do you think about when you hear
about prepper like Doomsday prepper or
survivalism right what do you think
about these people like oh these are
some crazy people that are thinking the
end of the world is coming and these are
hardcore right-wing people far right
that are like the end of the world and
they're going to take over and we got to
prepare for it and then all of a sudden
people get news that Mark Zuckerberg is
building aund million underground bunker
is that a joke no and by the way did you
know the W of the year for 2022 that
they added to the dictionary you ready
here's what the W of the year was for
2022 Perma crisis what's perac crisis a
word describing the feeling of living
through a period of Civil War inflation
and political instability has been
chosen as colins dictionary's word of
the year and what's crazy is when you
look at the Doomsday Clock that they've
been tracking every year from 1947 to
2023 you want to know what wild when you
look at this chart January 24th 2023
Doomsday Clock update a time of
unprecedented Danger it is 90 Seconds To
Midnight which means a lot of people are
worried that something crazy could
happen and that's a year ago a year ago
you know what wasn't going on October
7th what happened in Israel Hamas
Palestine and then 2024 election chaotic
craziness people are saying babe I know
we're we don't really care much about
politics but maybe we need to be a
prepar and you know what if something
happens to us in this episode I'm going
to show you different levels of how you
can prepare I'm going to give you
different kind of cars people are buying
to be prepared and different kind of
bunkers people are buying to be prepared
for
doomsday okay so if you get value out of
this video give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel here's what
we're looking at based on some data from
finder what are Preppers buying and how
much are they spending when it comes
down to what they're buying at the top
it's food and water then it's toilet
paper medical supplies survival kits
stash of cash home renovation
self-defense insurance and a few other
items and then when it comes down to
Sexes who is more likely to be a prepper
a man or a woman you probably guessed it
right it's men one out of three men is a
prepper but one out of four women are
Preppers by the way still women are one
out of four are like listen I'm going to
prepare for God forbid something crazy
happening to me and what's crazy is if I
were to ask you right now and say hey
which generation do you think is most
paranoid worried about what could happen
to them more Boomers millennial Gen X
gen Z what would you say what if I told
you out of all the different Generations
when you look at this gen Z are the ones
most concerned about what could happen
and they're the ones prepping the most
for emergency look at this here Boomers
all the way down at 18% you got Gen X
20% Gen Y 39 gen Z 40% so look I've been
in the financial industry since 911 the
day before 911 and I've owned stocks
bonds mutual funds real estate crypto
gold you name it I've owned it but the
one that's very important part of my
portfolio all these years is gold I love
having a percentage of my network in
Gold that I have access to in case of
many different things that's why we
chose to work with our new sponsor
American Harford gold if you have
retirement funds that you cannot afford
to lose American Harford gold will ship
physical gold or silver directly to your
door also if you have retirement funds
that you can't afford to lose now is the
time to call American Harford gold a
precious metal dealer you can trust they
have the finest products amazing
customer service and a buyback
commitment they've earned a five-star
rating from thousands of reviews and an
A+ from the Better Business Bureau tell
them I sent you and they'll send you up
to $5,000 worth of free silver on your
first order so text award value to 65532
or call
866695 7074 or go to American hardford
gold.com valayan and by the way you know
you can really break this down by region
How the West is the most with
preparedness then this the South you can
break this down all the way you want but
there's different ways you may be
watching the same path how do I prepare
for something like this there's
different tiers to it the range of
preparedness you can start off as basic
as $1,000 a couple different items you
can buy you can enroll in survival
training courses to learn about
essential skills such as Wilderness
survival basic Medical Care and
navigation or you can go $2,000 for
buying a tent a sleeping B portable
water filtration system and compact
cooking supplies investing maybe a
communication tool like satellite phones
and two-way radios to stay connected
during emergencies maybe it's a home
preparedness $5,000 installing a backup
power generator solar panels and a water
storage system at home reinforcement of
doors and windows for increased security
against potential threats maybe you're
going to go $50,000 to $500,000 remote
Retreat property this is purchasing a
remote property away from Urban centers
to establish a secondary Retreat
construction of a sustainable off- grid
cabin with its own water source solar
power and gardening facilities for
long-term self-sufficiency then you have
the customized survival vehicle this is
modification of a vehicle for survival
purposes including reinforced armor
off-road capabilities advanced
communication system installation of a
rooftop tent extra fuel storage and
other features for extended travel in
case of evacuation then you have
Community survival compound this is a
million bucks where you're building a
collaboration with like-minded
individuals to establish a communal
survival compound and this is this got a
kitchen Medical Center a bunch of
different things then you got private
Doomsday Bunkers which I'll show you a
couple of them and then you have the
luxury doomsday Retreat if you're
somebody that's in the level of man I'm
going to spend some money protecting my
stff on my family here's 15 best
survival vehicles that they're building
number one Mercedes-Benz G-Class believe
it or not is the best when it comes out
to this according to armor max which is
who's ranking these cars number two a
bulletproof Ford Raptor truck which is
pretty sick to have number three Jeep
Wrangler right is one of the safest four
look at this guy here Knight XV which is
apparently 15 armored SUV that thing
looks pretty insane by the way with what
it offers I'm kind of turned on by it
myself you got a Tahoe but this is not
just a regular Tahoe apparently some of
these guys are going to be bulletproof
you have the bulletproof Toyota helux
you have Land Rover Defender custom
conversion of it you have the Toyota
Tacoma Chevrolet Colorado Toyota FJ
Cruiser you got the Jeep Gladiator
Rubicon you got Audi 8 security you got
bulletproof Cadillac Escalade looks sick
you got bulletproof military Humvees and
bulletproof Bentley Continental and by
the way if you drive a Tesla Tesla has a
bioweapon defense mode it's an
additional model you could have bought
it between 2019 21 the upgrade was 425
again for doomsday type of situations
for some of you rich people you rich
folks that can afford to build yourself
a nice compound underground let me be
your realtor today on this video and try
to sell you by the way I'm I don't do
this I'm just joking with you some of
you guys are going to call and say Pat
I'd like to buy one from you let's take
a look at some of these crazy bunkers
worldwide you ready here here one the
vivos Europa 1 Luxury underground bunker
house just look at that picture right
there this is in rothenstein Germany 76
Acres above and below ground 34 living
quarters each 2500 ft kitchen bedrooms
Deluxe bathrooms living dining swimming
pool theater gym and bar so while the
world's coming to an end above you
you're watching a nice little movie and
just kind of shaking a little bit while
you're at a place like this in Germany
by the way this next one's pretty wild
this is the survival condo doomsday
bunker in Kansas us built from a missile
silo 50 floors with amenities like
shooting range rock climbing wall indoor
pool water park Library theater bar
fitness center and a command center it
can withstand a nuclear bomb 100 times
more powerful than the Nagasaki bomb
look at the way this looks like by the
way this started by Larry Hall survival
condo facility build within a former
Atlas F missile silo constructed by the
Army Corps of Engineers has more than
54,000 fet of protected space designed
to sustain 75 people for more than 5
years this next one is in Las Vegas it's
called the Las Vegas underground shelter
doomsday bunker massive
14,622 ft 26 ft below ground shielded by
the house above featur Spa pool Guest
House Fountain nightclub and a bar
nightclub five bedrooms six luxurious
bathrooms entry points designed like
rocks interior reflects Cold War period
this next one's called the Aristocrat
Rising S company features accommodates
up to 50 people hot sauna swimming pool
gym gamer Room Theater multiv vehicle
garage gun raate spacious dining and
living rooms this next one's called The
Safe House luxury underground bunker
house kind of looks like the house from
uh Purge if you've seen the movie Purge
above ground with glass windows allowing
natural light 6100 ft swimming pool
Outdoor Theater retracting Bridge
connecting Terrace and pool this next
one is vivos Indiana comedies up to 80
people for about a year common living in
dining areas Garden space for vegetables
laundry Leisure exercise and storage
this next one is V Vos XO you can tell
these Vios guys specialize in this
doomsday bunker in South Dakota us
largest doomsday bunker Community 575
bunkers each accomodating 10 to 24
people customizable with kitchen dining
living bedrooms and gym this next one is
the Green Brier bunker doomsday this is
in West Virginia US built to protect the
US Congress during Cold War Two meeting
spaces capacity for 435 and 100 seats
designed to last 60 days decontamination
showers at entrances that's very
important this next one's pretty sick
glow seed Vault this is in salard Norway
protects plant species in case of
Apocalypse houses up to 4 and a half
million seed varieties in three coal
storage units in the mountain for
natural temperature Cooling and by the
way I'll give you the last one call open
them there's a video matter of fact you
may be even watching this while I'm
talking over it doomsday bunker size it
features a
6,750 ft apartment and ground level Golf
Course helipad five-star underground
bunker and various amenity Spa swimming
pool Cinema Library Bar hospital and
this is in Czech Republic Europe This is
a business model they're building a
full-blown underground facility for you
to house your cars to be able to
entertain yourself to stay there not
have to worry about the nuclear attack
or anything that may be taking place so
if a company like opum is doing
something like this they're not doing it
because only one person is interested or
two people are interested or five people
are interested they're doing it because
there's a business model for this and
many people who can afford to do
something like this are making phone
calls to companies like this to say can
you please build an underground bunker
for us where it can be entertaining
luxurious protecting our car protecting
our assets and at the same time we can
enjoy ourselves there feel safe with our
family friends and people that we love
for some of you that are watching this
you're saying to yourself I didn't even
think about this stuff this is pretty
crazy like people like that are really
thinking about buying something like
this yes it's just like owning a life
insurance policy you don't buy because
you're dying tomorrow you buy because in
case something happens your family is
protected and many people who are all
about being prepared there's a famous
saying proper preparation prevents poor
performance the more prepared you are
the less you have to stress out if
you're married with kids and a family
and you can afford it at whatever level
it is you may want to consider preparing
for God knows what could happen in the
future especially with all the chaotic
times that we're living in today having
said that if you got value out of this
video give it a thumbs up and subscribe
to the channel we also did a video on
food shortage if you've never seen this
one before very interesting click here
to watch that video take care everybody
bye-bye